ça joue dur au congrès de la république
péruvienne ces dernières années le
président martin vizcarra qui s'est fait
le champion de la lutte anti-corruption
vient de tomber à son tour pour
corruption des pots de vin qu'il nie
avoir reçu quand il était gouverneur de
province en 2014 à deux mois d'une
première tentative il est destitué une
majorité écrasante pour incapacité
morale c'est lui manuel mérino président
du parlement qui accède à la présidence
jusqu'à l'élection de juillet 2021
ce politicien peu connues est
immédiatement assermentés ce qui
provoque des manifestations dans la
capitale des marques les manifestants
trouvent que le congrès souvent
discréditer n'a pas la légitimité
populaire pour destituer un président à
quelques mois d'une élection que s'il
est trouvé coupable de corruption il
soit jugé à la fin de son mandat le
président martin vizcarra s'est défendu
pendant 45 minutes devant les
parlementaires
ils ne m'ont pas écouté ou pas compris
at-il dit en quittant le congrès pour se
présenter devant les caméras il jette
l'épongé
we're all in
nous rions mieux musique je quitte la
présidence et je rentre chez moi
certains des présidents les plus
populaires des dernières décennies au
pérou il a réussi à garder sa popularité
durant pratiquement tous sont tous son
père mme ce qui est assez remarquable
martin vizcarra est devenu président
dans les mêmes circonstances en 2018
il était le vice-président de pedro
pablo kuczynski et il a pris sa place
quand celui ci a dû démissionner sous
l'accusation de corruption dans l'énorme
scandale de la firme brésilienne
odebrecht qui a touché tout le continent
il n'est pas le seul trois autres
présidents ont été mises en cause dans
le scandale
alejandro toledo 2001-2006 en fuite aux
états unis et menacé d'extradition
alan garcia 2006 à 2000 ans s'est
suicidé l'an dernier en ayant jusqu'au
bout les accusations koh lanta humala
2011 à 2016 en procès après avoir fait
de la prison préventive
enfin une des chefs de l'opposition qui
est cool j maury elle même accusée dans
le scandale de brecht a fait de la
prison préventive au début de l'année
alors va-t-on se débarrasser d'un
président gênant pour effacer toutes les
poursuites pour corruption de la classe
politique celle des affaires et de la
justice probable c'est vraiment un
président qui a été très ferme qui a
appuyé toutes les actions qui ont été
entreprises depuis deux ans et demi pour
pour faire enquête pour accuser pour
mettre en prison
une série de personnes impliquées à haut
niveau comme le péruvien ne sont
décidément pas au bout de leurs peines
jean michel leprince sera du canada
montréal